What could possibly be more frightening than
climate change, biological warfare, dying,
and -wait for it- Obamacare?
What about.... clowns.
Hi, jokers, it’s Natalia for DNews!
A legitimate phobia of clowns is called coulrophobia.
Although a lot of people are creeped out by
clowns, full-blown coulrophobia is not a common
phobia.
However, with the rise of creepy clown sightings
across the US and parts of Britain, we wanted
to know: why are people so afraid of clowns?
Is it an innate fear or a fear born out of
horror films, like “It” and “Killer
Klowns from Outer Space’?
Well, there is actually some science to back
up why so many people are creeped out by these
merry pranksters.
A 2008 British survey of approximately 250
children, found that nearly all of them thought
clowns, regardless if they were intentionally
scary or not, were ‘creepy’.
But how could Bozo the Clown be in the same
category as Pennywise from “It”?
An attribute of many clowns is their unwavering
dedication to sticking with ONE emotion.
A sad clown is always sad.
A happy clown is always smiling.
They wear their emotions like a mask with
painted on makeup and you don’t know what’s
really going on underneath.
This creates something called deindividuation,
which is when an individual’s identity is
obscured.
This applies to everything from burglars wearing
masks to individuals commenting anonymously
online-- ahem trolls.
Evolutionary Psychologist Glenn Geher says
that people who are in a state of deindividuation
are more likely to engage in despicable behavior,
like cheating and stealing.
So when we encounter someone like this, we
quote, “expect them to act at their worst.”
Humans don’t do well with uncertainty, including
unpredictable behavior.
In a study released by New Directions in Psychology,
researchers argued that creepiness was a bi-product
of ambiguity.
People feel fear when they know something
is going to hurt them, but if they are unsure
of someone’s behavior, the mere threat leaves
them ‘creeped out’.
According to the co-author of the study, psychology
professor Francis T. McAndrew, clowns are,
quote “mischievous, which puts people constantly
on guard.”
Think about it.
You never know what you’re gonna get with
a clown!
I mean, jeez, if clown car pulls up you don’t
know if you’re gonna be ambushed by 1, 5,
or 30 clowns.
Talk about about uncertainty.
For someone with coulrophobia, a clown car
is the ultimate nightmare.
Now, clowns also fall into a psychological
category called “Uncanny Valley”.
Freud came up with the term “uncanny”
to describe the phenomenon that humans experience
when they see something that is familiar but
is somehow off.
And the term “Uncanny Valley” was first
coined by Japanese roboticist Masahiro Mori
and includes almost human-like creatures that
aren’t quite human; they sort of trick our
brain, which in turn, creeps us out.
Like lifelike animatronic humans or a ventriloquist
dummy.
Clowns are human but they are an exaggerated
version of ourselves.
That makes them fit in the “uncanny valley”
valley.
And a lot of clowns are stuck in a permanent
smile.
When someone smiles at you, your brain often
interprets it as a nice, safe gesture.
But the brain can detect a fake or an unnatural
smile.
According to Harvard professor of Psychiatry
Dr. Steven Schlozman, your brain recognizes
that when someone smiles ALL the time, there
is something off, as with clowns.
Makes you wonder what their true intention
is- do they want to hug you or murder you
in your sleep.
So if you have a mild to severe fear of clowns,
you’re not alone.
But remember clowns are people too.
Even the creepy ones.
If you want to know more about the uncanny
valley and its effects, guess what, we have
a video about that that goes into more depth.
And what about you?
Do you like clowns, dislike clowns or are
a clown?!
Let us in the comments below and be sure to
like and subscribe for more DNews every day.